I wanted to mention something because I
used a gif of you because I love you and
it's funny so I I was having the worst
day ever literally my my dryer broke my
clothes ended up we have no clothes line
so I just have a hang him on that like
the back porch kind of area and they
flew off into the forest and I had to go
find all of them and anyway it was a
really rough day and then I got back in
and my I had all these texts and they
were like man so now there's murder
Hornet so I was like wait what and I
started looking up like what the hell a
murder when it was and then I anyway use
your gifts it was like sure like why not
yes like have you heard of murder
Hornets no I mean I had on you know I
was like this weekend reading a
newspaper article about it and again it
was just one of those things we did a
thing on our show called not now murder
warrants which is we don't have the
bandwidth to be worried about you at
this moment if you were if you were
looking to make a splash murder Hornet
so you picked the wrong time I think you
know you need to do it before or after a
pandemic in the middle of it
I think there are people who are at this
point you know would be terrified about
murder Hornets any other time but or not
alike great whatever bring it on let's
just have it all at once I'm honestly
like I and this happened me the other
day to there was an earthquake here and
I didn't know their worth quakes
happened in Montana and I was just like
where are the locusts coming yeah
everything is being it's just going to
crap I don't know what's happening but
it's not i but that was a bad day but um
anyway I just thought it was funny
because they like they're called murder
we're not apparently because they
decapitate honey bees they just head off
which I was like of course we would have
something called a murder Hornet right
now subscribe to my channel subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going